e un po come tornare a scuola dopo che
sono sei anni che il fatto il diploma
come tornarci rivedere cose
mamma mia sono invecchiato stessa roba
bella tutti ragazzi di questo lo video
siamo su facebook
parte 1 c'è anche una parte 2 ma la
faremo nei prossimi episodio vai al
gioco le scocche l'audio potevano
metterlo visto che non ci metti la
musichetta di sottofondo un po krypi
bravo già più bravo sì mi piace
l'obiettivo è cercare di riconoscere
perché ci sono riferimenti a film e
giochi sicuramente queste scream il
primo oppure il cupo mietitore di billy
e mandy non sono ricordate quello che
credo sia scream comunque l'obiettivo il
proprio discorso per chi non lo sapesse
è cercare di risolvere la faccenda nel
modo meno ovvio possibile e ha ammazzato
con un cucchiaio non so se ve ne siete
accorti cioè ricomincia comunque è molto
difficile spesso per questo motivo
perché devi fare cose che non ti
aspetteresti mai allora porco il demonio
non è l'unica cosa che io debba cliccare
magari lampada non ho cliccato l'indizio
non ho cliccato l'indizio cliccato al
lampadario dietro provate me l'ha usato
vabbè fa niente per questa volta josè un
inizio ma non volevo cliccare qua non
posso cliccar e neanche limitrofa mente
non esista lo stavano credo abbassiamo c
è la madonna sono diventato il gigante
colossale senza essere gigawatt
per madonna che ricordi bellissimi next
level ragazzi credo che comunque molto
intelligente ok ok questo questo già è
un'ansia perfetto vedo che ci sono degli
occhi che ci sono dei lombrichi grossi e
c'è un coso degli illuminati qua cosa
facciamo
ci parliamo ci che facciamo qua c'è un
armadio salve e quindi faccio cascare
l'armadio mentre non guardi ti faccio
usare la mano mentre lo guardi porco
demonio
non ho idea di cosa debba fare del vero
giuro le donne e over avete svitare la
testa
avrò capito come ho fatto ma cosa l'ha
spinta forte
ricordatevi che quando si girano le
teste negli horror si possono ospitare
anche i gufi fanno così un giro alla
testa non hanno girate seguti ma si
possono evitare autonomamente importante
questa anatomia degli animali buy e
familiari su questo canale c'è anche
cultura ragazzi questo è pietro ciao
ragazzi allora e chi chi sei perché ti
fa in sel fida questo sono io quando
accendo la fotocamera interna del
telefono effettivamente il naso
[Musica]
vi rendete conto che il mio lavoro si
basa sul nulla
i gremlins io ero troppo piccolo per il
gaming strato non li ho seguiti ma
vediamo rimediare subito con il forno
nel legno va tutto al fuoco ma cos'è
sulle fantò per una mera bevo l'altra me
la bevo e tap in al culo e giusto
[Musica]
allora io ho bisogno sinceramente di
qualcuno che mi spieghi le cosce nei
commenti per favore mischiate il livello
3 2 punti
e successo questo con linguaggio aulico
per cortesia non con cazzate perché io
ho bisogno di capire che la mia versione
che la mia mente è talmente superiore
che non riesco a capire cose base capito
questa non la capisco andiamo avanti
però ho finalmente high school musical 3
0 il distacco le catene no allora gira
la ruota gira a ruota non è quello io
apro le cose
roma ho capito l'aveva sei stupido forse
devo fare qualcosa mentre share mentre
mi ha in mano tipo è che chi con lui se
vedi come no io ok perfetto a prevedere
tedesco cliccare qualcosa mentre mi ha
in braccio
infatti prendere ok siamo così in un ora
e mezza la inserisco fa qualcosa hanno
come riclico muoio volevo fare qualcosa
sicuro ragazzi lo farei qualcosa mentre
di stritola peso tipo scorreggiare di
soggiorno comunque alto livello
intelletto credo sia qualcosa di pos
correggio tutti però vediamo lo devo
sgonfia ma sai che lo sapevo ce l'ho
visto che era troppo grosso il coso del
collo quindi ragazzi frankenstein
in realtà è un gonfiabile la cipolla
questa amadeus signa tracking error è
questa la mummia quella non cipolla
trova bene
è un clicker dire la stoffa
oppure è il demo gorgone di amo fatto ma
cosa no cosa ho fatto
va bene next non sto capendo che ora
forse forse twilight ma non è un horror
twilight cioè un film d'amore per
ragazzini e anche per me strisciando
addosso perché c'è bella vicino al suo 7
t 20 i tuoi l'anti ma poi io non sto
riuscendo a capire perché pisciano con
la fanta c è da lì che è uguale perché
pisciate con l'app che non potete far
vedere il pp ok va bene ma fai vedere il
getto del peso
cosa censuri piscio con la fanta non si
può pisciare sono parole della fanta me
mi sono pagato però va bene ciao bella
sono un cane che piscia piscia sono
pigio a lei ama i cani giustamente dal
posto perfetto va bene ok
credo sia lecito perché qui sarà un
ragazzo ha fatto la pipì per terra c'è
la gamba avete visto un ex finalmente
una roma che conosciamo tutti chissà se
c'è anche se lander man più avanti però
per adesso alien sono morto nella cosa
c'è lì che mi spaventa è questa fase la
mia fatta sul lettino la lingua
a un pp ma cosa cosa è successo
non capisco figlio grande olio o c'è
jason con una maschera molto più brutta
hanno forse michael myers non è michael
non so video e facciamo a fette il 17 di
potere faccia da culo e quindi bisogno
visto non fate domande perché non
capisco neanche io quindi è bello che il
suo shadow subito fantastico questo
ragazzi e l'esorcista in un film che ho
visto
e a me personalmente società mi ha fatto
cagare nel senso che non mi ha fatto
neanche paura non so anche blair witch
ho fatto il gameplay carino non
incredibile carino ma il film era nell
questo corso d'acqua non si non si bea
dolce che cosa la fa no perché sono sui
simboli sui muri paghi qualcosa tu ah no
c'è il magnetismo capito sono piena di
collane nella tasca e degli anelli e
quindi mi attacco subito ma ok ascensore
di nuova generazione
non ho capito cosa succede però è
posseduta mai sopra
porca [ __ ] però stai calma va bene
era molto più semplice di quanto
pensassero trascina alla fine la metà
delle cose le devi fare trascinando il
mouse ebbene questo tiro a indovinare e
the grudge da questa a noi mamma
ok questo questo è un bel film invece
cacchio per marino hanno fatto il gioco
che mi sarei preso infatti gratis e ciao
mamma che lo stai calma e comunque molto
più bella rigone del film regolari firme
molto più brutto alla signora tv la
porta ridicola portano aiuto e questo è
veramente difficile prosa non disse
ragazzi devo schiacciare più volte ma
cosa ma cosa che si sono trovati sti
dove comunque va beh complimenti
completi prima taloni anche quello
quello veramente incredibile ho solo
enigmista nella granella nella trappola
quella delle siringhe questo film è
orribile
vediamo se riesco ha sbagliato vuole
pubblicare indizio piccola pillola non
la voglio vedere la pubblicità in
gratis.it ingrandisci ti ancora c'è vola
verso la fine
bravo perfetto e va beh non è che non è
che se immune alle siringhe così prove
hannibal lecter che facciamo che ci apre
per hannibal lecter non puoi mangiarlo
c'è la maschera s'è incazzato ti
strangolo e ti mangio perché sono
animali metterlo comunque hannibal
maggio agli esseri umani non gli hot dog
quindi secondo me non serve non mangiare
lo dogma poi farlo c'è qualcosa fanno
fuori a sto punto in poi maledizione ma
dove vai
ma cosa non ho capito cosa è successo
quindi agli spaghetti ci passano di
passoni noodles numero ma dagli dagli
hotel il cibo preferito di hannibal
lecter dopo
gli uomini siamo arrivati credo
all'ultimo livello 16 a questa eden un
denim che significa la suora in inglese
l'ho visto butta giù il vaso salve
questo non me l'aspettavo se non me
l'aspettavo per niente porca vacca
quindi non tocchiamo la suora massei
giovanni allora posto ti tolgo i
pantaloni trolling trolls on
voglio la canzone è veramente completa
mister al turismo e sport 1 hanno fatto
anche due boe che già non lo fa il 2 io
lo faccio dice lo vorrei fare nel
prossimo martedì se mi fate sapere nei
commenti per favore che cacchio è
successo in questi livelli non mi dovete
spiegare ciò per quasi tutti i voli
almeno che ho evidenziato spiegatemi
perché non ho capito niente lasciando me
piace avendo sei piaciuto di scrivere al
canale ci vediamo prima settimana con il
prossimo episodio parte ii titolo best
of e ragazzi
[Musica]